[Music]
in this time period people couldn't just
drink water there was a lot of sort of
disease in water so in order to avoid
cholera you could make small beer which
would have a small amount of alcohol
content in it enough to kill the
bacteria and then you could drink it to
be hydrated without getting drunk so
small beer was really important in order
to keep a group of people say a group of
soldiers hydrated when they were out in
the woods you know patrol on the
frontier
I'm Thomas Landon I'm the assistant
director the manuscripts archives and
rare books at the near Public Library
and today we're looking at George
Washington's recipe for beer in his
journal from 1757 and by taking a closer
look we might learn that it wasn't as
delicious as we think we call it The
Notebook of a Virginia Colonel because
it was maintained by Washington as he
was captain of the Virginia regiment
this document is important because it
shows the personality of George
Washington which then becomes the
personality of the United States of
America Washington's notebook includes a
lot of things crossed out he did that in
order to prove they were done this helps
build the myth about the type of person
George Washington was he was exacting
deliberate and wanted to succeed
so when you actually look at their
journal you'll sort of see why the
recipe for beer is separated from his
his sort of goings-on as a Virginia
colonel Washington is known as a real
draconian he lashed people for deserting
we know of at least two times where he
honed people for desertion the beer
recipe appears at the end of the journal
and also upside-down which suggests that
it was added later because it's on page
one of the journal on its reverse side
in this time period there's not as much
stigma around drinking everyone drinks
children drink women drink and you drink
to survive and you drink beer because
it's clean so the drinking of beer was a
sort of everyday occurrence that all
people did in order to be hydrated the
beer recipe also is unappetizing take a
large stiffer full of brand hops to your
taste now there are lots of types of
hops brand ones don't found the most
most appetizing boil these three hours
then strain out 30 gallons into a cooler
put in 3 gallons of molasses ok so now
you've boiled brand hops you're adding
molasses so you have a kind of syrupy
elixir then while the beer is scolding
hot draw the molasses into a cooler let
this stand until it is little more than
blood warm then put in a quart of the
yeast if the weather is very cold cover
it with a blanket and let it work in the
cooler 24 hours then put into a cask
leaving the bung open until it is almost
done working the bottle at that day as
it was brewed so you're bought you're
not aging it today's beer makers would
never make this beer even the the most
sort of dedicated craft brewer would
call this beer sort of like water
sorry there's been a lot of focus on the
beer recipe and the reason why might be
because the military history of the
French and Indian Wars is not as
exciting as the recipe for beard which
humanizes George Washington he has this
sort of dual personality of being a sort
of militaristic person but also a
benevolent founding father and so the
beer recipe I think can be used to show
his human side this document has told
different stories to different people at
different times and that's what makes it
so alive and interesting is that there's
different ways to read the document
there's different ways to see it
[Music]